alors que le président de la république
a parlé d'une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation alors que vous avez
pris l'engagement de ne pas fermer
d'écoles ou d'hôpitaux sans l'aval des
mères vous ne pouvez faire exception
avec la sécurité la sécurité est la
première des libertés
une sécurité également répartis sur le
territoire est la première des justices
il n'est pas acceptable que les maires
soient mis devant le fait accompli alors
que bien souvent ils concentrent de
grands efforts comme à montereau avec
une police municipale de 28 à des gens
ma question est donc simple monsieur le
premier ministre pour éviter que la
sécurité ne devienne un élément de plus
de la fracture territoriale
prenez-vous l'engagement solennel devant
la représentation nationale de ne fermer
aucun commissariat de plein exercice
sans l'accord des maires alors oui à la
proximité oui à l'accompagnement de nos
concitoyens mais donnons à des annonces
qui masque la réalité des actions déjà
porté et développé par les élus locaux
madame la ministre mais question sont
les suivantes quelle est la plus value
de ces maisons france services qui les
portera qu'elle soutient envisagez-vous
d'apporter aux maisons de services au
public déjà existante est porté par
l'essentiel par les collectivités mois
j'exprimais dans cet hémicycle les
craintes des salariés de general
electric et des élus du territoire de
belfort
il y a deux mois votre gouvernement
affirmé suivre avec la plus grande
attention la réorganisation de general
electric
il expliquait souhaité accompagner le
développement d'activités nouvelles
telles que l'aéronautique le grand
carénage ou encore l'hydrogène
auxquelles je crois beaucoup plus
inquiétant votre gouvernement excluait
d'office son soutien aux projets liés
aux énergies fossiles notamment le gaz
comme l'exprimé votre secrétaire d'état
dans cet hémicycle le 4 avril dernier
vous avez même personnellement affirmé
qu'il n'y avait pas d'avenir pour le
marché des turbines à gaz
7 aujourd'hui que la nouvelle tant
redoutée est tombée une catastrophe
industrielle beaumont département pour
le nord franche-comté 1044 emplois
seront supprimés chez general electric à
bourogne
à boulogne billancourt et à belfort qui
va perdre 985 de ses salariés un salarié
sur quatre sera touché des drames
s'annonce des familles qui vont se
trouver en difficulté
mes premières pensées vont bien entendu
aux femmes et aux hommes touchés par ce
tsunami industriels monsieur le ministre
l'heure n'est plus aux petits
arrangements calendaire comme avec cette
annonce que le gie a opportunément
retarder jusqu'au lendemain des
élections européennes
les salariés ont besoin de réponses
concrètes quel choix stratégique met en
oeuvre votre votre gouvernement pour le
redressement de l'industrie belfortaine
quels efforts de réindustrialisation
êtes vous en mesure de porter pour ce
territoire et enfin
excluez-vous oui ou non les projets liés
aux énergies fossiles le projet de
fusion renault fiat chrysler une fusion
qui évidemment a des aspects séduisants
comment ne pas avoir envie de créer le
numéro un mondial
si on considère l'alliance avec nissan
et on voit bien effectivement la
complémentarité géographique qui
pourrait y avoir dans cette alliance
malheureusement nous avons de quoi être
échaudé avec la politique de fusions
acquisitions cher au président macron et
je le dis aujourd'hui en pensant aux
salariés ex alsthom devenu ji à belfort
un mariage entre égaux à l'époque qui
tourne au fiasco social puisque en trois
ans on est passé de la promesse de créer
1000 emplois un plan social de 1000
emplois au passage d'ailleurs le
président république nous remercier son
ancien collaborateur
monsieur baylet d'avoir attendu le
lendemain des élections européennes pour
faire cette annonce
en toutes circonstances même lorsqu une
fusion a du sens d'un point de vue
industriel de ce ministre il s'est peut
être le cas ici il ya toujours un revers
de la médaille qui se décline dans un
triptyque réduction des effectifs
pression sur les salaires pression sur
les prix des sous traitants s'il est un
sujet de société qui peut nous réunir
c'est bien la bataille à mener tous
ensemble pour les personnes handicapées
tel est le message que je veux partager
à l'issue du congrès national de
l'unapei à lyon auquel j'ai participé
cinq cent cinquante associations 3000
établissements et services
médico-sociaux plusieurs milliers
d'hommes et de femmes engagés sont
déterminés à accompagner chacun grâce à
une solidarité nationale et qui tape sur
tout le territoire
une solidarité qui permet de financer de
nouveaux établissements et services de
proximité de ce que la risée plus
d'enfants de garantir l'accès au travail
à la santé d'offrir partout en habitat
adapté
je ne doute pas de votre volonté madame
la ministre
mais j'ai entendu le regret du président
de l'unapei qui évoque je le cite une
politique du gouvernement
trop souvent déconnectées de nos
réalités des réalités de celles et ceux
que nous accompagnons tous les jours
pouvez-vous nous rassure et rassurer les
familles les professionnels les
personnes concernées qui n'ont pas votre
vision de l'inclusion
tous veulent la reconnaissance de la
place de chacun car chacun doit choisir
sa voie et vivre sa vie beaucoup de
jeunes adultes handicapés de notre pays
attendent une place dans des foyers de
vie mais pour l'heure ils ne peuvent pas
rentrer au domicile familial car ils ont
besoin d'une prise en charge que seuls
des professionnels peuvent leur garantir
les jeunes polyhandicapés sont
particulièrement concernés ils sont plus
de 850 âgés de 20 à 30 ans à être
maintenu dans un établissement pour
enfants
ces sites cette situation reflète le
manque cruel de places pour ces jeunes
adultes
d'autant plus que nous avons bien
conscience que cela reporte le problème
sur les plus jeunes qui doivent attendre
plus longtemps que des places se
libèrent madame la ministre vous ne
pouvez ignorer la détresse des parents
qui sont épuisés moralement et
physiquement j'ai donc deux questions à
vous poser de la part de ces familles la
première vous engagez vous à maintenir
le dispositif dérogatoire de
l'amendement créton pour qu'aucun jeune
majeur ne se trouve sans accueil à temps
plein deuxième question allez vous
augmenter le nombre de places dans les
établissements pour adultes et à quelle
échéance
[Musique]